dashing through the snow on an 80
horsepower snowmobile is nothing unusual
in the forests of northern Sweden
tourists can drive snowmobiles
themselves here too but their first
given a lesson German Patrick Oh Dhaka
shows them the ropes he knows just what
the holiday makers want budget for this
may be one which we not to human eye a
German tourists always want to see how
the road signs are a real hit the cold
water they get stolen all the time
that's the one people want to hang up in
the living room and they want to get a
look at a good old red fox or arctic
foxes further in the north and there are
a few wolves too they come over from
Eastern Europe power finds it is also
most mobile [ __ ] hair comb there's
plenty of room for wild animals the
human population density in Lapland is
about to residents per square kilometer
the area is known as Europe's last
frontier
in northern Sweden temperatures of minus
20 degrees Celsius are normal in winter
and it's dark the Sun stays below the
horizon for two weeks but you get used
to it but it cuz he was a little mr.
Warren ever been depressed at least I
haven't been I read a lot and enjoy it
it's a good opportunity to exercise my
mind if it's a bit cloudy when the Sun
is below the horizon a few Sunbeam still
light up the clouds from below when the
sky turns wonderful colors notions
publish be human deaths taking a long
walk is also a nice way to find inner
peace money should not become in a
wealth of him one attraction you can
walk to is the ice hotel it takes more
than a thousand tons of ice and quite a
bit of snow to rebuild it every year
artists from all over the world
contribute sculptures during the
Christmas season the whole place is open
and guests can spend a chilly night
there
karuna Sweden's northernmost town isn't
far away 18,000 people live here some
140 kilometers north of the Arctic
Circle among the locals are Swedes fins
and indigenous Sami who gave the place
its name in their language karuna means
ptarmigan a member of the Grouse family
Sami traditions are also reflected in
the hotel camp reponn both in its
furnishings and its cuisine chef marcos
us on cooks meals using old recipes that
have been handed down through
generations in the north we lots of
reindeer we are with the elves and
pretty much what's around what's around
us in this restaurant we use much things
just from the from the region
so in addition to reindeer there are
lots of root vegetables from Corona he
says his cooking secret is less is more
I used the knowledge that I got from my
ancestor them the reindeer and the meat
and the fish from here I think it's a
good and it's so clear and reach in
their tastes so we don't see something
so much yeah you can almost taste that
we are gearing up I know where the
reindeer has has has wandered and I know
where the roots are from a knife that's
good thing to know things take time in
Marcos you and Sons kitchen he does slow
cooking this reindeer shank has simmered
in a pot for five to seven hours he got
the recipe from his grandmother
there are also regional accents in the
interior design of the hotel it's
clearly Nordic and the materials come
from the area around Corona and above
all there's lots of birch
Monica lint introduced the regional
emphasis at Camp reponn she grew up in
corona and has been running the hotel
with her family since 2003 I am a winter
winter woman I'll have the wintertime
and winter activities and so I I think
that I like the dark time when you can
make it cozy inside a lot of fire and of
course the no delight guests can watch
for the aurora borealis in Canberra puns
Northern Lights Hall but it's hard to
predict when the colorful stratospheric
show will begin those who don't want to
wait inside can head outside hop back on
a snowmobile and drive through the
winter wonderland